so
[Music]
in so far as self-consciousness
one-sidedly grasps only its own
externalization then even though its
object is for it just as much being
itself and it knows all existence to be
spiritual in nature nevertheless true
spirit has still not yet come to be
explicitly for self-consciousness
inasmuch as being in general or
substance has not equally on its side
implicitly externalized itself and
become
self-consciousness for in that case then
all existence is spiritual being only
from the standpoint of consciousness not
in its own self
spirit is in this way only imagined into
existence this imagining is the
visionary dreaming which insinuates into
both nature and history into the world
and into the mythical ideas of earlier
religions another esoteric meaning than
that which lies on the surface and in
the case of religions another meaning
than the one known in them by the
self-consciousness whose religions they
were
but this meaning is one that is borrowed
a garment which does not cover the
nakedness of the appearance and merits
neither belief nor reverence it is no
more than the dark knight and
self-delusive rapture of consciousness
paragraph
756 is a relatively short one but it's
also
a very important one packed with all
sorts of stuff both looking ahead where
we're going and also just looking back
to the previous several
paragraphs i think it's also
a very rich paragraph because it
contains
an implicit criticism
of
several different things including what
might be seen
as hegel's
own practice later on
in for example the lectures on the
philosophy of religion so this might be
giving us a clue
about how to read that other work and
how not to
misread it it also includes a very clear
critique of what we can call esotericism
or sometimes people call it mysticism
hegel despite what some people want to
make of him i would say certainly at
least in the phenomenology is
not only anonymistic
he is an anti-mystic he thinks that if
you can't
articulate it in language
and if you
can't
make it conceptual along the lines of
the big griff and also if you can't
bring it into reality vehicly kite and
practical action
what you're really dealing with
is something that you have made up it's
not just complete nonsense
but it is
something that is less than it pretends
to be so but we'll get to that in just a
moment
so
what we have here if we go back to the
previous paragraph
is a double
externalization right
externalization and oyster rung
this is an important term
and it's it you know it's central to you
could say the hegelian way of
looking at dynamic development things
don't just you know transform into their
opposites the way it's often portrayed
rather
they
externalize themselves and this means
going out into a world that is not just
them in which other things push back in
which they have to fit themselves into
frameworks the externalization of
oneself or of a substance means being
part of an entire
matrix of things and this is something
that's been going on throughout the
phenomenology this that was there in the
consciousness section where you know
we're mostly thinking about doing
epistemology what is it like to be a
knower
but the
objects themselves
externalize themselves for
consciousness and then we have
self-consciousness right and there's
externalization that's taking place
there i see that other
self-consciousness over there and i'm
like there's a piece of myself over
there oh my god how do i get it back or
you know we have the battle to the death
or master slave dialectic or we have
stoicism skepticism unhappy
consciousness
these are all modalities
of the externalization of
self-consciousness as is
the reason section which has greater
affinities at least until we start
getting into the ethical stuff halfway
through
with the consciousness section and then
we have the massive spirit section then
we've been looking at religion this
entire time in this this penultimate
section of the work where there's this
interplay between consciousness and
self-consciousness so externalization
that we've arrived at
in the the last paragraph making fully
articulate what's going
on there
now hegel is issuing to us some
warnings not about externalization
but about how
it's understood
what we
make of it
and this is not a
simple warning this is something that
requires us to do a lot of
thinking it through
mulling it over as i said lingering
over this section and thinking about its
implications it it requires us
you know as do many of the other
paragraphs in hegel's phenomenology but
this one especially
to do
conceptual thinking about it and not
just representational thinking about it
because
rather than just for stealing us denkin
right so this is uh
quite important now let's get to the
first line we haven't actually talked
about the text quite yet insofar
as self-consciousness one-sidedly
grasps only its own externalization okay
so
here we have uh you know a typical
phrase of hegel einstein one-sidedly
right
hegel is uh
very concerned as are many other
philosophers to do justice
to what is actually taking place and to
show us
he doesn't just want to say well
this is one way to look at it don't look
at that anymore
look at it the right way over here he
wants to show us what happens
when we get things wrong
in doing so hegel is
part of a long line of philosophers that
don't really constitute a tradition but
you know if somebody like aleister
mcintyre is right this is part of what's
in any healthy functional tradition
is not simply
providing the right answers but showing
what happens
when we get the answers wrong and why
people do get them wrong as a way of
understanding how to get to
where we need to go there's going to be
some big implications for for this
so self-consciousness one-sidedly grasps
only its own externalization
what are we talking about there so we
got to go back to the previous paragraph
right
externalization happens to two different
things in the previous paragraph
substance and self-consciousness now
when
hegel describes how
substance is externalizing itself at
this point
in the phenomenology
what does he
tell us he tells us that
let's go back to 755. we've got these
two sides that spirit uh has right
spirit is gonna be their unity substance
alienates itself from itself and becomes
self-consciousness okay so that's a
proposition that we had a mode of
articulation right linguistic and
thoughtful articulation no mysticism
there right if it can be expressed as a
proposition azat's in hegel's point of
view and he goes and he says the
externalization of substance it's growth
into self-consciousness so this is not
just a
boom it's done we have a paradigm shift
and suddenly
substance becomes not only conscious but
self-conscious no there's a growth
that has been taking place through the
centuries
and in a
number of ways it's not a simply linear
process there's a lot of fish tailing
back and forth and sometimes retracing
your
steps and so he goes and he says it
expresses the transition into the
opposite
the unconscious transition of necessity
in other words
substance is in itself
self-consciousness and this is
you know so when we try to summarize
hegel's points of view this would be a
good sentence you know substance is
itself is in itself self-consciousness
doesn't realize it at the start but
that's something that we've achieved at
the end right it's not something we can
simply begin with in explaining hegel we
need to get there
so substance as it externalizes itself
becomes self-consciousness not just
consciousness self-consciousness with
all that that implies
you know given the self-consciousness
section desire
uh being itself in the other we go on
and on and on the need for recognition
now he also tells us that
self-consciousness externalizes itself
so what is that this is a bit different
it's not just a well you know substance
self-consciousness realizes that it's
substantial that's not what he says
he tells us that it realizes that it is
the universal essence the vason
or since the self is pure being for self
which in its opposite communes with
itself that it is just
because substance is self-consciousness
for the self that it is
spirit so we've got a lot of moving
parts there substance self-consciousness
self spirit
now
if self-consciousness grasps what's
happening here
in a one-sided way that only focuses on
self-consciousness and its achievement
it kind of loses a good bit of the
picture right
self-consciousness
needs to remember
this is going to be this is not in the
text but this is worth thinking about
self-consciousness needs to remember
that it is itself
an externalization of
substance could be substance with a big
s or a small s
right we never
completely free ourselves of our
materiality of being
bodies of being embodied minds of
existing in
social structures one of the important
substances is not just like metaphysical
substance you know going back to you
know aristotle and that which remains
unchanging you know during the accident
no no no it's the ethical
substance as well
and
what divinity is supposed to be so
substance is here kind of a
catch-all term
substance is
the self
now here we get to
the mistake right
so
insofar as self-consciousness
one-sidedly grafts only its own
externalization
then even though its object its
gegenstein what is presented to it is
for it just as much being just as much
actually essence as
self and it knows all existence to be
spiritual in nature
all existence is spiritual being right
all existence is gestic is vision
um
[Music]
nevertheless true spirit
has still not yet come to be explicitly
for self-consciousness now that doesn't
mean that it isn't there it can be there
implicitly right
miller uses implicitly he as a way to
translate on zeke um
it has not yet come to be for
self-consciousness in as much as being
in general
vason right or
or substance has not equally on its side
implicitly
externalized itself and becomes
self-consciousness now this is
interesting
being in general or substance has this
implicitly externalized itself and
becomes self-consciousness
hegel in the previous paragraph said
well yeah that that has happened
what does the on zeke they implicitly
mean here
usually
in in hegelian dialectics and you know
we have to be careful about generalizing
too much because we've got to be close
we got to remain close to what actually
happens in the text
you typically have just like you know
with you have certainty get this height
and then you have truth you know
or you know var height and then we want
to have truth and cell certainty at the
same time we often have you know the in
itself the on zeke and then we have the
four itself the physique or you know for
another or there's other variations and
then we want to have the in and for
itself right the on and for zeke
just as we often take that as a starting
point
in some cases it might it might signify
something
a bit different so
does being in general or substance on
zeke
uh has that externalized itself and
become
self-consciousness
you know we have to be a little bit
careful about what we mean here
has this book
become self-consciousness i mean it's
certainly a repository and a
representation not only of somebody's
self-consciousness you know hegel but
all the other things that are packed
within it but insofar as we consider it
in its materiality
no it's it's
it's not a self-conscious thing the book
is not like hey greg you haven't read me
for a while i'm kind of missing that i
have hunger desire be geared for
recognition from you i mean look at how
the shape that the book is in too i have
not been treating it all that well these
many years that i've had this copy i
probably should you know get this bound
or something like that that would be a
way of showing respect and perhaps a
kind of reciprocity towards this tool
the book that i i have so hegel can't be
meaning that like every single thing in
the universe has its own little
consciousness and we're all part of this
vast network that we have to take into
account that that that doesn't make
sense is what is going on there
um
so there has to be something else
going
on and we're going to come back to that
in in just a moment but let's think
about this so
he goes on
and he tells us
in that case
all existence is spiritual being
only from the standpoint of
consciousness not in its own self
all right so what does it mean to be
spiritual being geistic is zion or vasem
what does it mean for us
we're already that
so we approach a question
of something that is
kind of muddled for us but about which
we already have some presentments and
we're already behaving as if we are
spiritual beings when we allow ourselves
to degenerate just to the level of
machines or something like that that is
a degeneration right
what does it mean for the rest
of the
cosmos
or even just the world
let's stick to you know the earth
what does it mean for the rest of all
those things
to be spiritual being i mean it is
tempting to say well they're just what
they are for consciousness right we are
the privileged being and i think that
hegel thinks that we are in fact the
privileged being it's pretty clear
through the rest of the phenomenology
right
and yet
things are not just what they are
for consciousness slash
self-consciousness
there's always more
and that more
has a kind of dynamicity to it it can
affect us
in important ways
so
we don't want to see spiritual being
only
from the standpoint of consciousness we
want at least some things to have their
own self
and he goes on and here's where the
cautions come in
if we
do this sort of thing where we make
consciousness and and when we're doing
that we're not making consciousness for
say we're making our consciousness the
standpoint of our perception
our
imagining
our interpretation we're making that
paradigmatic
he says that um
all sorts of problems
come about
all existence is spiritual being right
only uh from the standpoint of
consciousness spirit is in this way only
imagined
into existence
geist
right this um unity of these two
externalizations
is only
imagined ein build it
into
existence dazn
and we could interpret this as you know
spirit is given in existence but it's
only an imaginary existence so therefore
it's just for us it's not in itself
right and certainly not in and for
itself in that way
or we could think of a collective
imagination that that could be taking
place as well you know consciousness
self-consciousness spread across
groups you know for example researchers
talking about religion in the
late
18th and early 19th century that hegel
could be targeting here right i mean
he's targeting plenty of people in a
present that's
far beyond him in time as well because
people keep making the same mistakes
so something only being imagined not a
good thing for hegel right
imagination is connected with
foreshadowing
you know representation picture thinking
which is not yet conceptual uh
right
what does this lead us to
so
a whole bunch of
mistakes
he says spirit is only imagined into an
existence this imagining ein gebilden
is and here's how uh miller translates
it visionary dreaming shramarai right
um you know enthusiasm just kind of like
roaming and ranging over all sorts of
cool stuff the way people do when they
get drunk at parties or high and start
rambling on and on oh man everything is
connected oh you know
i've never seen things in this way well
that's trumarai right that's that's we
might say bullshitting
right it's uh bullshitting about things
that that really matter oh man if we
only saw things the right way hegel's
like yeah get out of here uh
you know
whatever you want to call the people
that were dealing with there and he says
that insinuates or you know another
translation
is um
more linguistic and talks about speaking
right
or reads things as the the german is
unsure lakes right
literally lays underneath something
but you know is interpreting it could be
another way but so this visionary
dreaming insinuates into
different things something that it
shouldn't
what is it
insinuating into
now here's where um
miller's translation
you know you could find a little fault
with it
so he's got both nature and history and
it's it's not just both nature and
history it's uh you know into nature
zovol
into history right so just as much into
right so it insinuates in insinuates
these things into nature
how it understands nature how it
understands the natural world including
our own selves as parts of nature and
then into history
history is the distinctively
humanized and human reflecting
and human agency part of nature that is
you know estranges itself from nature
and in a way becomes master over nature
doesn't it right so
insinuates into nature and history and
then into the world isn't that an
interesting
thing to say world encompasses
both nature and history right
world also takes us back to
the different worlds in hegel's
discussion think about the three
different worlds in the force and the
understanding section that are not
different worlds from each other but
overlap and intersect with each other
into the world just as much as into
mythical ideas
of earlier religions
right
what does it push into that what does it
lay under it what does it insinuate into
that another
and hegel doesn't use the word esoteric
he uses the word inner right
but we can translate that as esoteric
because the people who are like all big
into esotericism what does that actually
mean it's the hidden inner kernel of
something that the initiates or the
people who have the code get to see and
all of us poor slobs on the outside only
grasp the exoteric the external meaning
of it what dummies we are right we're
not grasping the inner meaning
hegel says that this inner meaning is
insinuated which means that it's not a
real inner meaning it's a fake inner
meaning that is imagined by these people
hegel is sort of here being anti-gnostic
you know an anti-esotericist
and anti-mystical an esoteric meaning
that is different from
what appears on the surface they are
shining right what what uh uh
miller says what lies on the surface
so it's insinuating this into nature
it's insinuating this into history it's
insinuating this into the world it's
insinuating this more concretely into
the mythical ideas of earlier religions
hegel's saying this is how you get
religion wrong
this is how you
put your own perspective in there and
screw up your process of inquiry
and misrepresent things
he goes on and he sort of like
he consolidates this insight and he says
and in the case of religions
another meaning
zin right then the one known in them by
the self-consciousness
whose religions
they
were right this is really quite
important
hegel
is telling us something that people in
the field of religious studies and i
would say in other fields have come to
stress as well we don't if we want to
understand
a
religion
we cannot simply arrange it in our
pre-formed schema
and you know set it out there and while
this represents this and this represents
this and it's all neat and tidy or
something like that we actually have to
think about what people who live who
believe who act within who defend who
reform that religion what their
self-consciousness of that religion is
so we can't for example reduce
zoroastrianism
merely to the religion of light as now
who did that
hegel himself
earlier
in the nature religion
section this is where it gets really
interesting and tricky doesn't is hegel
criticizing his own practice here i mean
there's plenty of places in the lectures
on the history of religion where he uh
exhibits great insight and and you know
does penetrate into the the
consciousness of those who practice
their religion and there's other places
where you're like wow hegel you're
totally off base there
how did you you know wind up with this
very outsider point of view that
attributes things to the people of that
religion who don't really view the world
or themselves or the gods or whatever
that way
this is this is a very common problem
in
the history of comparative religion or
religious studies isn't it
he goes on and he says this meaning
is one that is borrowed
it's a garment that does not cover the
nakedness of the appearance
and merits neither
belief
nor reverence
so you can't
inject into somebody else's religion
that's no longer
yours your own points of view and get
out of it what you aim to do think about
all the
neo pagans of today neo-paganism is
arguably from the religious perspective
religious studies perspective a
new
uh set of religions not a revival of an
old set of religions for exactly the
reasons that hegel is talking about here
one is sort of cutting and pasting and
you know
modifying things and putting them in
there and saying here's the real core of
it no the real core was way back then
and it was lived out by people then and
if you want to understand it you need to
find a way to get into their
consciousness not just tell them the
dead people who have nothing else you
know no response to give you that they
actually believed and thought all of
this sort of stuff
so he goes on and says it is no more
than the dark knight and self-delusive
rapture of consciousness
okay where does this metaphor of the
dark knight come up
at other places in in the phenomenology
the preface you know
and other places where
what
consciousness or slash
self-consciousness is doing
is
engaging in its own imagining and then
trying to claim greater meaning there
greater reality
and instead we have to
enter
into the genuine consciousness now is
this supposed to be just a backward
looking thing we're like hey we don't
want to uh mess up the past
yes and no i mean hegel is going to
start moving to thinking the event of
christianity
right not not just the the beliefs the
doctrines the church the event the
coming to be
of this
in his view massively important world
religion
and he's giving us some cautions about
that and this is actually quite on par
so the last thing i'll say about this is
you know if you think about what's come
to be called the quest for the
historical jesus
albert
schweitzer uh you know not quite 100
years ago but i think pretty close said
that it's very much like somebody
peering down into a well and seeing
their own reflection there there's so
many people who you know tell us what
the real jesus was and it's almost
always ein building imagination on their
part jesus was a wandering cynic sage
well if you're the kind of person who
wants to read that in then you will
right jesus was and we could pick all
sorts of other things that get pinned on
him usually
there's there's like a beef going on
there and the church has got this wrong
and all the other scholars have got this
wrong
well i mean maybe that's the case but
you got it wrong too because you're just
relying on your own
refined imagination and injecting into
the consciousness of this founder
and their his followers
what you think it was supposed to be
rather than
showing a certain kind of receptiveness
that would allow
spirit to
show itself
you